look at the top comment of every video
dude how long are you going to cuz you
started this bit and everyone think like
oh dick is funny you think I have the
power to start bits it's on that's them
doing it yeah dude everyone thinks I run
the
JK the Instagram page it's me
[Music]
baby welcome back to careful boys where
we are afraid of everything check check
out the merch go get a link in the
description box if you're afraid to got
crumbs all over his shirt speaking of
that today we are talking about what we
love about JK a that's a nice wholesome
s very sweet just wait till the next one
the next one is what we hate about JK oh
oh but that's the next one right now
we're doing what we love yeah uh I love
that there's an endless supply of like
water and drinks and alcohol for us
that's tight that's pretty sick I like
how you started with water the water's
handy dude water's handy cuz we start
with water in the day water and then you
know there's like
bull we ate coffee and everybody did we
just show up and then there's coffee
it's not Vietnamese coffee all the time
cuz that's the hitter but that's intense
we can't have it all the time like
intense that's like play we had to do
budget cuts but maybe because people are
buying shirts we can actually get
vietnames coffee again and some Banes
maybe my my favorite thing is um how
much we have each other's backs in here
oh yeah cuz it's a very
H it's a very like you could speak your
mind type of place and we always have
each other's best interest in mind and
also we have each other's backs first so
if like let's say Anthony says something
crazy like 9/11 didn't happen we'll go
like but what you mean is is this and
he's like no I really do mean you mean
when you guys say it and then when I go
guys stop saying it and you're like oh
Double Down say and then I'm like guys
stop saying you're like yo we should
make a t-shirt I'm like no you can't
make a t-shirt t-shirts yo we got to
make a t-shirt were we going to make a
t-shirt many many t-shirts it's like
it's almost like you don't have my back
five times in a row and they cancel each
other out but we don't agree we all
voted that we we don't agree but we have
we have each other's backs it's a
writer's room in here and it almost
feels like the ultimate practice of
empathy you know like we you like we try
to get what everyone is saying and then
we try to make put everyone's best foot
forward for each other having a good
time and I that's like one of my
favorite things because it's even hard
to practice that in the real world you
know like in the real world it's like
you can do something positive and
someone takes it negative versus in here
we can almost purposely try to do
something negative like the way Anthony
does but we'll still make it positive
like the way you guys negatively talk
about what I do but then you make it
positive I don't understand that's too
much science yeah no you're supposed to
empathize and back it up yeah yeah not
all the time we're not going to do
all he almost con convinced us that the
towers didn't go down I I thought about
it I watched he sent me loose change I
watched that's what you think that they
didn't go down at all he sent me a
document no he sent me a documentary
about it I watched it like a good friend
but I think the real convincing one was
his performance k b noodles.com
kjas.com buy our merch K aesthetic
store. kjas.com sign up for kindas Dojo
online yeah go to Costco get the k b
noodles online beginner tutorials if
you're thinking about starting Journey
mer on Alibaba I have to say it's really
close the dance is what really got me
make sure you sign up for all your stuff
going off of that though I really like
that I feel like JC has the audience's
back two and away oh and I noticed that
like kind of like after handling like so
much of the socials for like over a year
now like the amount of people that will
write in and be like uh oh this channel
really represents how I feel about
certain things that are maybe not the
most common way of looking at it I like
that we're not trying to appeal to
[__] everybody that it's like if
you're in here we're taking care of you
if you're not a sensitive [__] and you
have a sense of humor there's a group
there's content for you and there's like
a community for you and us exactly yeah
and if you are sensitive [__] there's
so much content for you out there you
don't you don't need us to be there too
well that's the default content yeah but
if you are sensitive [__] maybe this
content is for you you know I me oh it
help you out Harden you up a little bit
yeah
teaching you good things in a guess what
we survived but BuzzFeed didn't cuz
they're stupid big but also we had way
less overhead yeah that's we didn't have
investors either what has JK ever
officially apologize for anything yeah
yeah couple times we do apology video
every year I think every year every year
we did some we [__] up somehow yeah
we'll be like oh [__] we [__] up there
that that joke was a little too far
really uh yeah there's no reason to
bring it up yeah yeah we should say the
exact thing that you guys did wrong I
think we're good also like we've been on
we've been on social media for 16 years
right so like me and B are almost 40 so
like people grew with us from basically
College [__] dumb asses to adult men
dumb asses so from young dumb men to
dumbest older man never raised one IQ
point but but but Grew Older maintained
and I think there's it's ult to be
online for 16 years and not [__] up once
or say something stupid once especially
in the world that we're in if you're
talking for hours and we're [__] just
experimenting here like some people have
scripts and they still [__] up you know
so that's true
yeah is pretty semi it's semis scripted
we're just throwing out ideas all day
long and some of them are horrible ideas
what about all the you know you got the
dumbass college man I grew up to grown
ass dumbass men what about the women say
something nice about the women Joe the
women are dumb asses for watching us and
enjoying this content and wanting more
well said yeah but they're also probably
the most down toe chicks you could find
if they like this content cuz that means
like you understand like a a different
level of humor and how people can [__]
around and know what people really mean
you know what was pretty awesome is we
did a uh uh the Juni grand opening meet
and greet out in Irvine and it was
actually our first meet and greet since
lockdown yeah and that was about over 3
years ago that we were just like man I
don't know you know like we're not
getting the 300,000 views per video that
we used to and all these things and I'm
like what's going on now like and who is
our fan base now and because we've been
online for so long like we have people
who like grew with us since high school
and now they have families and they
brought their kids and then they're like
yo we all watch it together together and
we have new fans who are like college
students that are going to Irvine and
they're like yeah I just found you guys
last year and then so it's such a huge
age range now of people that are
watching like you know people that are
in their mid-40s maybe in Hawaii we have
fans that are like even in their 50s and
stuff so like it's a massive different
group and I'm like when people find us
that are new it's interesting cuz I have
this idea that new fans are like more W
and less into comedy the way that we
grew up enjoy but they like it too so
I'm just like I don't know it's it's a
it's an
interesting exper experience to seeing
our fan base not only grow but like
stick with us for like decades I like
how like when when it comes to women
like when they're they're reaching out
to us one of my favorite things that
these [__] say is like hey like I've
learned more about how men think because
I watch JK and I think that that's
really cool like that that um you know
maybe there was some questions that they
had about like they don't understand men
and how they think about it but these
[__] will watch us and they're like I
like how I'm learning about like how
guys process information and how guys
aren't as easy to like share information
and stuff like that so I like that you
know what's weird there's like a whole
movement right now with like guys going
out there talking about dating giving
advice all this stuff right but none of
them are actually married or in
successful relationship yeah they have
zero experience and it's the same thing
with the with the business gurus or the
real estate gurus that don't own
property they don't actually do business
um but they're out there championing all
that stuff and I'm like it's it's it's
so odd right that like you people are
seeking advice from from people that
aren't even doing what they preach yeah
we're not an advice Channel but we
actually do all those things like we all
own businesses we all have long-term
relationships we have long-term
relationships with friends and all that
stuff and we have conversations around
that but um we're not really that
channel yeah of like giving that advice
we like being dumb as funner yeah I
think that's what I love about this
place me too is that we put dumb as the
most biggest priority and all of us core
values all of us hate to Market
ourselves exactly
that's so true all of us have the skills
and we can laugh at all the people who
Market themselves extremely well but
have no actual skill MH and we make fun
of them and we hide especially Nick here
we hide the actual skills and the
business behind everything almost to the
point where we sabotage our success he
even hides a skill in the ring yeah I
just get knocked out all the time it's
really fun cuz I feel bad for the other
guy you know I don't you like what's he
going through yeah he probably trained a
lot so yeah I like the fact that people
can learn off of mistakes that we share
like real stories where you genuinely
[__] up you know that's Co that's the
best way yeah exactly rather than
telling people what to do it's like n
it's better to be like look what I did
see how that works out learn from our
mistakes do you think there's something
that's like
um so the way you motivate people right
is sometimes you have to be kind of
superficial to get them there first but
then when they're there they like oh
that's just not the real [__] so for
example right people that are not they
don't understand what wealth is they see
a guy pull up in a Lamborghini with nice
like suit and jewelry they'll be like oh
that guy's balling but then real wealthy
guys would look at him and be like I
don't really know if he
is is he posing yeah so then like you
know some some of the wealthiest guys I
know would like wear like hammy Downs
are just they don't give a [__] about
that stuff because they're so in their
business right
but um maybe maybe that's what it is is
like to get that mainstream appeal you
have to look and dress a certain way or
like well you have to appeal to the
Primal yeah cuz I think we're a second
layer deeper it's kind of like it's hard
to get people to go hey you have to eat
more vegetables but if you go hey you
want a six-pack and then they start
living the six-pack lifestyle and they
and they actually become healthier
versus hey you should be healthier but
that's so like second level and I think
that's for us too we like the the guys
that have a Lambo you appe you you um
you have to attract the Primal and then
afterwards they go oh this is how you
build a business so the people that know
how to tap into that they're really good
yeah cuz didn't you say something like
you have to get fit cuz you can't be a
fat gym owner cuz you think it's funny
to be a fat gym owner but you're act you
you're very knowledgeable and you can
act you're you're actually competing you
can hit like all the you know you do
things athletically well right but then
like but it's funny that though the
image it's like you put comedy first I
still like fat Bart more that's I do too
fat Bart is funny we hate skinny Bart we
have each other's backs
well this might be going to a different
territory but that's the observation
that I have about us and that we don't
necessarily
like focus a lot on the imagery and
sometimes that is self-sabotaging where
this channel can be much bigger and
better in a lot of ways but we kind of
so focused on the realness of our
enjoyment here that all those other
things get kind of neglected that's also
why I think our fans ride with us for so
long because I think we
putation first second is authenticity
and they really feel that so like the
other people it's like if they put like
appeal to the Primal first then they're
like wait what the [__] your
relationship isn't really like that or
that's not how you live your life and
there's they find all these other things
that conflict with how you guys present
or how they present themselves we've
been presenting ourselves the same exact
way for like 16 years like these guys
are really as as they say they I also
like that's refreshing I also like how
this room we can we can [__] around and
we do but we don't [__] around too much
I think we especially this group I think
we found a good balance with each other
of like how much how much stupid [__]
are we going to do and how much like
serious like actual like maybe depth um
things that we do and like the balance
of those things like um I don't feel
like we just like destroy every positive
thing with for a joke real quick like
kind of like ta kti's last couple
movies like I feel like you know we have
that hard and then we don't take away
from it always so that's true yeah we're
not always looking for setups and [__]
yeah I also enjoy the ride uh there's
something more uh I don't know that you
feel connected to it like if especially
in this era the Attitude Era and the
careful boys if we came in everything
was just glorious the whole time I think
maybe would have less of like a passion
towards it but there's something about
watching us kind of [__] fall first
yeah yeah the sinking [__] I think we're
falling like that yeah yeah when did it
go you know what we are we are a Fix and
Flip okay oh we're a we're a we are a
when you look in a Craig so you're
saying we're going to sell out
eventually okay when you look into
Craigslist ass ad right
when you look at Craig's ass we are a a
a car that says TLC needs TLC yeah needs
work $500 OBO that's what we are and the
interior is all [__] up you can see
all the the foam underneath the leather
but what we are is we we're the we're
we're the we're the guy that looks at
that and goes you know what there's
something here and then you make uh a
detailing YouTube video cleaning it up
fixing it and then you go how I turn
this Civic from $500 to $1,000 I think
that's what our Channel and then in
parentheses cuz I'm
a took 16
years I put in $33,000 to make 500 bucks
what do you like Nick not much no
um I like honestly the boys I just like
hanging with the boys dude but also
being a part of something that's you
know bigger than what you you are or
what you do and I think I'm here for
well I don't even know why I'm here
sometimes but I I'm here because of you
guys like I I really do like that aspect
um and also too it's like how can I say
no to being here you know what I mean I
think you guys make it really easy in a
good environment for us
to have deep conversations and we get to
talk about real stuff but also just
crack the stupidest jokes that we would
never be able to do anywhere else how
can say no to all the extracurricular
activities I don't say no to all the
extra I got tattoos with you bro how
dare you how dare you you can always
throw that back it was a first tattoo my
first tattoo my wife hates me CU of you
dude but when you when you said you
weren't going to come here it was so
believable that's [__] up see that
makes me mad I was like cuz when I
rewatched that video Bart reacting I was
like this [__] thinks I really
wasn't going to show up that's [__] up
you think I'm [__] the snaky guy dude
yeah dude but I don't just cuz I don't
and all the times I bailed on
experiences was for legit reasons like
what he was saying although to have
Barts back he was saying usually Nick is
down so he that's what that's what broke
his heart but your acting was also
really good yeah your response of of him
saying where you at and you saying what
do you mean was genius I didn't know
what to
say I didn't know what to say that's
smart yeah you just asked questions back
at you dude yeah and he's like what do
you mean what do you mean and also too
like seeing how long you guys have been
established in this space and then I get
to come on and write coattails is pretty
cool that's what you think you're doing
but you're really helming the ship like
honestly like you're the captain right
now [__] you dude you're the funniest
guy look at the top comment of every
video dude how long are you going to cuz
you started this [__] bit and
everyone thinks like oh dick is funny
you think I have the power to start bits
that's on that's them doing it yeah dude
everyone thinks I run the JK [__] the
Instagram page like hey Nick post this
on the I'm like dude I don't run
it's me baby that's your [__] my
favorite
[__] and you're going to get a mimicking
me and people actually believe
it I got to stop saying baby so much
with so many ease every time someone
messages and goes who's running this
account it's Nick baby what's up caps
dude no but in seriousness like it is
cool to I know you guys are all going to
roll your eyes and all that [__] but
like it is cool to be with uh amongst
people who are like you know Titans of
of their industry in a lot of ways I
think that's kind of cool don't look at
me like that [__] you [__] you [__] you
[__] you see self- sabotaging Mark anti-
marketers no I I think it's true though
man I do I do agree I really like that
too I like that everybody here like like
is sitting on top of something they're
proud of and selfishly I get to learn a
lot from all you guys like with it's
business and you know just learning how
to do this [__] show like it's I
think it's really cool do you think you
wouldn't have been a good host for us if
you weren't doing this for so long yeah
absolutely but don't you do that and the
barbell talk show and even the barell
talk show I'm like I know I'm here David
CH gen you're like [__] do you get
the most do you get the most practice
here out of all the other you do more
content than like all of us yeah it's
true you're you're un you're doing more
content than me it's true you are
pretending like he doesn't do content no
well it's just like you know the oo
stuff is like we're [__] where's a
startup you know what I mean so it's
like I think yeah yeah the the volume of
videos that we shoot here makes it so
much easier to do any their video I
think you should start hosting here too
n dude hey let us know in the comments
if you want Nick to start hosting here
with electric we're not even going to
know what the article is be deflecting
the whole
time I deflect his own article I'm like
H you know what guys I don't want to
talk you know what you know would be
funny is this is what I imagine if I
started hosting halfway through I'll be
like sorry guys this is like not a good
article my my favorite thing though I
will say my favorite thing is that if
you want to see Nick host it's only on
patreon where he's getting electric
shots and it's never just hosting it's
like it's there's a catch and Nick gives
up the first awkward pause Nick gives up
on the article yeah guaranteed dude if I
if I if I have the floor and I start
talking I say one word I'm like the one
word I said was a bad choice of words
already in my head that's what I think
whatever singular see already [__] up
I don't understand plurals and singular
let us know in the comments if you want
to see
no don't [__] but also let us know in
the comments what you guys like about J
cuz I think it'll be interesting to see
[Music]
yeah